this Inn has been in the Hardesty family
for four generations and I can't
understand why TJ and Chris have no
appreciation for what has been given to
them I've called a staff meeting and I'm
hoping this will get them talking before
they lose their family heirloom it's why
I'm a quick chat with you all my first
impressions have not been good but I
struggle to believe that you two are
brother and sister it is shocking no
communication not even looking at each
other why can't you two at least talk to
each other get frustrated with some
things and my other time we talk and
talk about the whole [ __ ] and we never
get anything done
how do you think this is what your
father wanted no it's an absolute now
what's wrong with this place I am why it
was management you know thank you would
be nice every once in a while you know
that's all I ask for
I'm more hurt than angry because I care
so much about them he sound like he
pushed the breaking point yeah I felt
like TJ and Christopher don't give a
[ __ ] I don't know how much more I can
take
trying when did the drive go out of the
kitchen when did the essence when did
the word passion disappear I've never
seen all three in that kitchen ever ever
I feel like I am the voice of truth
everybody else either one doesn't care
or two they just don't see it I've been
saying since day one that this kitchen
is a joke there are no standards in the
kitchen chef
it's depressing [ __ ] Cheyenne his
opinion doesn't really matter to me
never has ever well I watched you in the
kitchen it was like you were just hired
as an extra and TJ your feud with your
brother is clearly getting the way of
running your business
the staff are desperate and you know
what hurts it's a blessing that you've
got this place the potential is huge yet
you walk around and treat it like it's a
curse
I came to you're in as a guest and I am
NOT [ __ ] happy both of your
sleepwalking to disaster go to your
office and at least try to talk if you
can't talk you might as well close the
doors right now
you know in the 30 years I've been here
I never had anybody ever complained like
that and it makes it tough and then
throw at my face even harder you know hi
okay what's wrong you really gave me a
wake-up call because this place is toxic
TJ has issues I think she's a control
freak and you talking to them they're
standing there as far as I'm concerned
they made asses out of themselves I'm
done here
I cannot work here no more this is your
life this is your yeah and it's
destroying I can see that they don't
care about us they need to hear from you
okay I can't believe it's come to this
as far as I'm concerned TJ and
Christopher they're not gonna change
it's a total shame hey how are you I
[Music]
can't I can't work here anymore I'm
sorry it's destroying me I don't like it
you know I care about everyone if my
stand out here you don't you make people
feel uncomfortable and I'm telling you I
don't know whether anybody else is gonna
speak up I'm not saying that I'm perfect
by any means at all either but you know
I don't think that there should be
personal attack this is the way I feel
whether you guys like it or not because
it's just killing me I feel as though
there's no future I'm done
you're giving me a look like every
single bit of that is just a fight a lot
of the [ __ ] she says is true TJ nobody
wants to [ __ ] talk to you I am NOT
gonna have her tell me that I'm this
mean horrible monster that doesn't give
a [ __ ] he thinks you're a mean horrible
[ __ ] everybody I really think you need
to [ __ ] talk to somebody or do
something before you're in a padded
[ __ ] room I disagree the proof is in
the puddin you're strung out your
[ __ ] tweet right to the [ __ ] end
every day because you don't have any
help
and then he turn into a miserable
[ __ ] psycho [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up
she didn't know what she was [ __ ]
talking about and she could drag her
[ __ ] ass did I ever say anything